depuis le début de l'attaqué russe en
ukraine de l'armée de vladimir poutine
est accusée vous savez de crimes de
guerre de crimes contre l'humanité parce
que le cible entre des objectifs civils
comme la maison qu'on vient de voir mais
aussi parce qu'elle utiliserait des
armes qui sont prohibés on parle ici de
bombes à fragmentation de bombes terme
aux barriques on va aller sur le terrain
en ukraine emballé dans la ville de lviv
où on va retrouver jonathan pedneault
c'est un chercheur auprès de la division
crises et conflits de human rights watch
bonjour monsieur pedneault
bonjour madame brûlés expliquez nous ce
que vous faites sur le terrain en
ukraine pour votre organisation
alors je fais maintenant plus de sept
jours que nous sommes à vivre dans l'est
que dans l'ouest de l'ukraine on
rencontre ici notamment dans les
stations de trains et d'autobus des gens
qui fuient les combats à l'est de
l'ukraine on rencontre les gens au
village à garde qui ont froid qui ont
faim ils nous racontent comment les
forces russes donc
en grande partie ont bombardé les villes
où il se trouvait précédemment à l'un de
ces de ces témoignages ont depuis dans
si jusqu'à présent à l'utilisation de
bombes à fragmentation d'en jouer dans
trois attaques lundi a acquise libérer
complètement à l'aise du pays et on
continue ce travail de cul de
documentation justement de violation du
droit du droit de la guerre qu'est ce
que ça fait une bombe à fragmentation
quand ce sont des bombes qui explosent
en plein air en fait tu ouvres en plein
air et qu'il est alors qu'il est tombé
des dizaines voire des centaines de
petites munitions de petites bombes à
retardement pratiquement si parfois
explose sur un impact mais qui peuvent
parfois ne pas exploser exploser plus
tard paraît ce sont des drones qui sont
de manière inhérente
indiscriminée et cause grave grave
danger pour les populations civiles dès
ce moment la tacc également à la suite
de l'attaqué comme je le dis si petite
bombe peut qu'exposer n'importe quel
moment et
causé de graves dégâts le chevoir est
demandé partout visibles dans les
allégations qu'on entend d'armes
prohibées on parle aussi de bombes terme
aux barriques est-ce que vous avez les
témoignages qui vont dans ce sens
pour l'instant nous n'avons pas de
témoignages qui confirment cela
ceci étant il faut être très clair les
bombardements qui se poursuit
actuellement sur l'idée de karski de
marioupol évidemment de la capitale
qu'yves sont les bombardements
incessants qui met gravement en danger
les populations civiles évidemment il ya
plein de types d'armes d'armes qui
peuvent être utilisés dans le contexte
de cette creil de cette crise mais au
final une explosion j'ai entendu une
explosion une explosion et canet des
civils qui se trouve à cet endroit
évidemment climatique est quelque chose
qui doit être condamné et éventuellement
un gaufrier l'en but d'obtenir on espère
de la justice pour les victimes
parlez-moi de cette attaque aussi à la
centrale nucléaire est ce que c'est
quelque chose qui va faire l'objet aussi
de votre investigation ou déjà le simple
fait qu'on le sache maintenant parce que
c'est démontrer que cette centrale a été
attaquée c'est considéré comme un crime
de guerre
c'est une attaque extrêmement
problématique qu'il pose demain risque
une main c'est la vie des gens qui se
trouvent aux alentours mais évidemment
dans d'autres parties du craint devoir
de l'europe je n'attaque qu'on est en
train d'essayer de documenter il n'est
pas entièrement un entièrement clan pour
l'instant à notre connaissance que
l'objectif est et et endommagé la
centrale est bel et bien en dix combats
alentours de la centrale mais le simple
fait évidemment que des armes soient tus
juillet à proximité d'installations
comme celle-là est extrêmement
problématique et demande de la part des
combattants qu'ils exercent la plus
grande pris les plus grandes précautions
il n'est pas clair que les russes fait
fusiller toutes les précautions
nécessaires pour éviter une catastrophe
nucléaire la catastrophe
environnementale on continue en travail
j'y comprends exactement ce qui s'est
passé sur place à cet endroit mais c'est
extrêmement préoccupant il ya des
allégations site de la part du
gouvernement ukrainien qui accusent les
soldats russes d'avoir commis des viols
est-ce que vous avez de l'information là
dessus est ce que c'est un volet de
votre enquête aussi
je n'ai pas présentement quelque chose
que nous avons publié par nous aimons et
au cours de multiples applications qu'on
se doit pour notre part de documents
pays on ne peut pas prendre le goût de
quelques parties au conflit que ce soit
que ce soit les autorités ukrainiennes
les autorités russes une grande partie
ne travaille justement c'est de
rencontrer les victimes les témoins
directs de c'est de nous assurer
justement de trianguler d'information et
il advienne à vérifier avant ma public
mais quand ce n'est pas ce sont des
allégations que nous avons pu y ait de
nombreux comme vous a mené cette enquête
au sein de notre équipe nous sommes
présentement quatre personnes qui
travaillons sur le terrain évidemment
l'organisation human rights watch une
organisation que dès que des employés un
peu partout dans le monde a une grande
part de l'organisation est actuellement
monopolisé bon déployer justement sur
cette crise qui est une crise
véritablement
d'une importance
impressionnant encore mais c'est une
crise extrêmement après tu parles pour
tout le monde combien de temps vous
allez rester comme ça à rencontrer des
gens à prendre leurs témoignages
c'est très clair que notre travail de
notation vont continuer c'est un travail
qu'on a commencé en ukraine de cela
plusieurs années pour applique la guerre
en ukraine n'a pas commencé la semaine
dernière mais bel et bien en 2014 il
dans les régions habite en basque dit le
masque la crimée de l'omsc se sont se
sont débités fondé des opérations
militaires et des abus également qu'on a
documenté depuis ce temps là mais on va
rester jusqu'à ce que on sentait que les
choses se calment pour l'instant c'est
loin d'être le cas et qu'est ce qui va
arriver par la suite avec toute
information vous allez récolter l'eau
que sa semaine cette information cette
enquête le
monde et je devrai d'avoir le batteur
indépendants qui sont justement des
tâches et des autorités ou des parties
au conflit c'est quelque chose qu une
valeur en soi qui permet justement par
la suite ou diplomates aux autorités de
différents gouvernements qui cherchent à
mettre une fin à cette crise en ukraine
d'obtenir des sillons fiables sur la
tenue ce jour voilà je suis sur les abus
qui peuvent être commis par ailleurs
d'une part comme de l'autre il faut bien
que mon jeu est bien clair qu'on ne fait
pas que
[Musique]
mettre l'emphase sur les activités à
milita joue pour nous n'importe quelle
partie au conflit et plus
malheureusement commettre des crimes
donc on s'attarde à appeler vérifie les
activités des autorités ukrainiennes
comme des autorités russes
s'il est pertinent dans le cadre de
notre camp mais c'est véritablement la
protection des civils je suis qui
suivent une souffrent le moins possible
en contexte de ce qu'est ce qu'elle
entrait en triple le canada a invité
cette semaine la cour pénale
internationale enquête est justement sur
des gestes commis par la russie à
l'endroit de la population civile en
ukraine est ce que votre rapport va
pouvoir être réutilisés finalement par
la cour pénale internationale
évidemment quelque chose que le
procureur de la cpi devra décider par
lui-même on espère évidemment que des
enquêtes journalistiques
les crimes qui ont été commis choix soit
jugé que la responsabilité soit attribué
kébé conséquences à ses yeux cela
mais effectivement ça j'ai bon c'est une
question
ou non et j'aimerais qu'on termine en
vous donne un peu de temps mais ce péno
pour nous parler de vous rencontre parce
que vous vous corrigez de l'information
mais pour rencontrer beaucoup de gens
vous les voyez les ukrainiens dans quel
état sont les gens que vous rencontrez
qu'est-ce qui vous disent qu est ce qui
ressort de ces échanges
mais il est évidemment dans plusieurs
dans plusieurs endroits qui sont
présentement sur le coup des pluies de
bombes sous le coup des bonbons on parle
de populations qui n'ont pas connu la
guerre depuis
depuis effectivement la galère la
seconde guerre mondiale je suis encore
des zones nord de la ville de kiev par
exemple ou des zones centrales du pays
et damas est différent dans complètement
dans l'est du pays valoir ce que
le dôme bas c'est la crimée qui qui
vivent sous sous l'occupation depuis
depuis 2000 14 mai
donc si ce sont des gens qui sont
véritablement à pour utiliser un
artifice
sont pas
ils sont pas habitués à ce type à ce
type de conflit à les gens
sont ils enfin ils ont froid ils sont
ils sont tristes ils ne comprennent pas
ce qui se passe ils cherchent à fuir
il faut se rappeler également que d'un
homme un chrétien a interdit la sortie
des hommes entre 18 et 60 ans du pays
donc on en achetait a énormément de
suite de scènes assez déchirant tout bon
aller à des familles se retrouvent
à être séparés alors que les femmes et
les enfants qui te faire d'autres pays
les ombres est derrière est vraiment
personne ne signifie pas ce que l'avenir
est là alors c'est assez c'est
extrêmement dur finalement vous êtes
témoin d'un moment de l'histoire qui est
tellement semble se pète ne sont pas de
facile votre travail non plus fait pour
vous même
bon évidement ça s'est défini mais on
est on demeure extrêmement chanceux pour
l'instant dans un appartement chauffer
on à la nourriture on est en sécurité y
en a des collègues qui veillent sur nous
c'est pas le cas de la plupart des gens
à défiler qu'on rencontre qui a fui les
combats ils ne savent pas du tout
lorsqu'ils retourneront à la maison
c'est fait voilà c'est une tragédie que
vit cette population monsieur pedneault
dont vous êtes les yeux et les oreilles
de la planète imposé sur ce conflit
actuellement merci pour votre travail
qui est essentiel et merci beaucoup pour
le témoignage aujourd'hui
perçues merci beaucoup pour voir nos
émissions en entier rendez vous sur la
chaîne i cirdi
oh
[Musique]